Morning, Jacob.
Hey, good morning.
Hi, how are you?
Good, how are you?
Good, good, thanks for asking.
So, what are your plans this coming holiday?
Oh, let's see.
I'm going to sell the...
The main city that we're near.
is the capital of the state, so it's Columbus. They throw a huge fireworks show on.
Okay.
Ohh, nice. When was that? Is it is it gonna be Saturday on Saturday?
So that's tomorrow.
No, it'll be tomorrow night.
Ohh, okay.
So, I'm going down there.
And my dad is in town visiting from...
Florida, so I'll spend the weekend seeing him.
Mhm.
That's pretty much it.
That's nice.
I think I'm going to go over to a friend's house on Saturday for a cookout too. So all sorts of stuff. I'm a busy guy.
Well, I think you deserve it. Everyone deserve it.
Okay, so shall we start? Or do we need to wait for someone? And by the way, unfortunately, Andrea will not be joining because she's not feeling well since yesterday. So I think she's going to be back by next week. So, yeah.
Yeah.
Noel.
Okay.
Okay, yep, and Lisa's on PTO, so it's just the two of us.
Kour.
Alright, it's gonna just just simple reporting and it's gonna be quick, so I don't want to waste your time, so I'm gonna share my screen.
Yeah.
OK.
All right, so this is for our monthly review for June. So the drill, again, agenda check-ins, highlights, tracker performance, see set analysis, way forward, and recap. So before we start, Jacob, is there anything that I need to cascade to?
Mhm.
Derek, like updates or new process that we need to follow in the next coming months or days?
No, nothing right now. Yeah, it's not a whole lot right now there. I mean, we're working on a bunch of stuff, but it's still in the in progress state. So it's nothing to change right now.
Okay.
All right, all right, so let's move on to highlights. So, in regards to Derek's attendance, basically he's having perfect attendance streak for the month of June with no late and absences, which is great. And he also shared with me, like, he's familiarizing himself to Mac OS.
Mm.
Support by handling issues and learn from them. So because we have training or devices here that they can use for them to familiarize themselves for Mac OS issues. So this past few days, he's very keen on learning.
the in and outs of Mac OS. So he's doing a great job in terms of that. And also with Jerry's, he maintained a low level of non-billable utilization throughout the month, demonstrating a strong focus on productivity and value-added activity.
So, yeah, I'm not sure why he's exerting the effort this past few weeks, but he's doing a great job in regards to that. Yeah. Any feedback in regards to those highlights, Jacob?
Yeah.
No, I agree his.
Just his work. This month has been...
Very good. I mean, yeah, like you said, he's very low admin time. He's been very productive. It's been great.
Yeah.
And he's bugging me. He's sitting in front of me. He's looking that he knows that we're talking about him.
PH.
Ha.
Ahh.
All right, so let's move on to his performance analysis. So the KPIs, you already know this, the utilization, ticket close per day, SLA, same day resolution rate. So in regards to the utilization, like we've mentioned earlier, the non-billable utilization that he has is.
very promising. It's very low, which is doing a great job. He demonstrated steady upward trend utilization, culminating in the strongest performance during week 4. Week one was the lowest utilization point during the reporting period. But basically week 4 recorded the highest utilization reported period. And
Mhm.
During the reporting period, Derek achieved an average billable utilization of 24.75, showing an overall positive trend across a four-week period. So hopefully, in the next coming months, he'll be going to still maintain this kind of utilization.
increasing the billable versus the non-billable. In regards to ticket closure, Derek achieved an average resolution rate of 87%, demonstrating consistent ticket closure performance throughout the reporting period, while week 4 recorded the lowest resolution rate.
It is also had the highest ticket volume with 46 tickets worked and 37 closed tickets. Week 2 represents the highest efficiency level across all four weeks. And during the reporting period, Derek achieved an average ticket resolution of 87 percent.
successfully resolving 113 of 132 tickets handled, which is very good. Performance peak is on week 2 with 100% resolution rate. Any insights on this, Jacob?
Nope.
All right.
So, way forward for Derek, he'll still going to coordinate with dispatch team. I think he's doing this as until up to this day. I think that's the reason behind the low non-billable utilization that he has, because he's communicating internally.
If someone needs help or if there's any tickets that he can work on, he's taking ownership of those kind of tickets. And yeah, tomorrow, Derek will be on holiday. So he'll be back on Monday. So
Mhm.
Yep.
Yep, we're we're all off tomorrow, so...
Okay, all right. So I'm not sure if I've followed this up with you in regards to Build It Live for August. So is there anyone who's going to join or we're going to pass this? Okay, we're going to pass this.
I don't think so. Unfortunately, I don't think it's going to be something we can do right now.
Mhm.
Okay.
All right, so in regards to Team GPS, like I mentioned last time, Jacob, if you want to try this, just feel free to message Andrea or myself so that we can assist you with this one.
Yeah.
All right, so before we end this service call, Jacob, is there any particular that I might need to know aside from the things that Andrea mentioned to me a few days ago or feedbacks for Derek and things needs to be done from Jerrick's side?
No, I think, I mean, I gave him a little bit of feedback this week on a couple tickets, but it wasn't anything major, just small things to make sure he's doing due diligence and making sure we're going, you know, looking at every angle of something. So for example, there was a ticket where a user had requested a quarantined e-mail be released.
Okay.
Um...
Mm.
And based on my analysis, I would have not released that e-mail.
just because I do believe it was a phishing attempt. However, there were no attachments, there were no links, so there's very little room for the end user to cause any issues. But he did release the e-mail. I just, I wouldn't have just because a couple of factors in terms of the...
Thank you.
Mhm.
The user ID of the e-mail address compared to the actual e-mail and the domain, I would just, it's someone just trying to cause problems.
Okay. Rest assured, I'm going to talk to Derek regards to that and find out what, why did he release that. But yeah, I'm going to talk to him in regards to that. And lastly, Jacob, I've talked to Derek two days ago. He's asking about
Kip.
I'm not sure what was that. It's an incentive every month or what was that?
The linear incentive, yeah, linear.
Neiler.
Yeah, now your bonus.
What is he concerned about?
He's just following it up, so...
Has he, is he concerned he's not getting it or?
Yeah, he's not getting it, he said, for the past three months. So I just want to double check.
Mm.
Okay, yeah, I'll have to check with our team. I'm not sure. I don't really...
handle any of that, I can...
Oh, but is there any in particular he needs to communicate that to?
I mean, to meet would be best because I can have the conversations with the people that need to.
But.
I'll reach out and see what I can find.
Okay, all right, I'll inform him about it. So yeah, anything else that we need to discuss, Jacob?
No, I don't think so.
Okay, so again, Jacob, thanks so much for allocating some time for us to discuss the service call for this month. And yeah, enjoy the rest of your day and enjoy the holidays. Happy weekend.
Thanks. Yep. Take care. Bye.
Alright, bye.